[Music]
today companies need to share and
synchronize more data with more teams in
more locations than ever before a number
of file sharing and synchronization
services claim they can help but they
don't allow you to seamlessly access and
share data between multiple clouds and
on-premises infrastructure from your
desktop and these services slow down and
become unreliable as shared files and
directories grow and workflows span
global distances there's a better
solution
IBM espera drive extends the benefits of
the espera high speed transfer and
sharing platform right to your desktop
so you can share and exchange virtually
unlimited size files and datasets
regardless of where that data is located
or where it needs to go using the same
core fast technology used in all a spare
a high-speed data transfer solutions IBM
espera drives integrated desktop
experience enables your teams to
remotely browse and access files and
folders stored in the cloud and
on-premises data centers with an
easy-to-use interface easily share files
and data globally just drag and drop
files and folders to and from remote
shared directories and workspaces using
Windows Explorer or Mac finder quickly
send and receive large digital packages
front from your desktop and receive an
email notification upon download
keep remote teams in sync enable
background synchronization and automatic
package receipt to your desktop to
ensure constant mirroring of files and
folders stored remotely keep all data
secure whether stored on premises or in
the cloud using the espera platforms
powerful built-in security model a
spirit Drive combines authorization and
access control for users and groups with
encryption to protect data over the wire
and at rest
a spirit Drive works with the latest IBM
espera on cloud hosted service as well
as IBM espera as fast specs and shares
offerings enabling you to use your
desktop to transfer and synchronize
files and data sets between your desktop
and
cloud environments at unrivaled speed
IBM espera drive your most powerful
integrated desktop solution for quickly
sending sharing and synchronizing data
of almost any size around the globe want
to learn more to see for yourself how
IBM espera can truly transform your
business visit us on the web or contact
us to schedule a demonstration or
evaluation
you